what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and it's about time for me to do
another dragon ball super review because
things are getting
very interesting so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you do enjoy these
dragon ball super reviews and want to
keep them coming then the best thing you
could do
is channel the super saiyan within and
smash that like button until it's blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future dragon ball
super videos and while you wait for the
next
exciting chapter to drop feel free to
check out our dragon ball version
podcast where i'm watching the series
from beginning to end with my friend
who's never watched the series before
link to that podcast is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all i
gotta say that i wasn't loving the
beginning of this arc at first
but with this chapter i'm definitely
hooked it took a little bit of time
but now i'm invested in this arc and
can't wait to see how it turns out
you can let me know in the comments how
you've been enjoying the granola
arc so far and what you think of it i'd
love to hear your thoughts
but back to this specific new chapter
which is called the universe's greatest
warrior
as far as titles go it doesn't get much
more hype than that
except maybe if the title was goku
unlocks gear 5.
that would be a pretty epic crossover
but we're back to granola
making a wish using another new set of
dragon balls we didn't know about
i love how no matter how long the show
keeps running they always find a way to
incorporate dragon balls into the story
as if to say
yeah the title is still super relevant i
don't mind though
because this was interesting stuff this
time only two dragon balls were required
rather than seven and granola got them
both granola
by the way is the last known survivor of
the syrian
race a race of aliens that were all but
completely destroyed
by the saiyans under frieza's orders he
wants revenge against frieza but he
doesn't have the power
so he wishes to be the greatest warrior
in the universe notably
the dragon mentions that this wouldn't
count the gods themselves
this is one of those wishes that i
wasn't really sure if it would be
possible to realize or not
not everything is fair game for a wish
from a dragon since the power of the
dragons
is limited i assume this wouldn't be
possible however in this case
it would be possible if as we find out
later
he shortened his lifespan from 150 years
left to
three years left as the dragon explains
he is able to multiply granola's current
strength by condensing
any and all power he could have
accumulated in his lifetime and the dude
agrees
saying he will do whatever it takes to
get revenge
at first i wasn't a big fan of this dude
because he wasn't one of our main
lovable characters and i felt like when
he was on screen it was taking away from
the time those guys would have
and he also didn't seem strong enough to
even be relevant
but he's grown on me and he's definitely
strong enough now i'm a sucker for good
revenge stories and granola's definitely
got that going for him and i really like
how much this arc is incorporating
history by involving the history of
frieza and the saiyans that we're
already well aware of
we also jump back to vegeta training
with beerus
to use the god of destruction powers
while goku
is refining ultra instinct i gotta admit
i wasn't sure
how it was going to go when vegeta said
he would find his own path to surpass
goku but i like this approach god of
destruction vegeta
is hella hype and i'm just glad that
vegeta is going to be able to stay close
to goku's level
and rival it somehow watching a god of
destruction vegeta versus mastered ultra
instinct goku face off down the line
would be
so awesome as beerus is teaching vegeta
about the destruction move he explains
that the target is completely erased
from
existence they turn something into
nothing and when matter is destroyed
it releases a heap of energy beerus says
the explosion is the highlight of using
destruction i also love the fact that as
he's training vegeta he's reading comics
just like elder kai and dragon ball z
when he was training gohan good to see
that the gods respect
manga if even the gods read them then
you can bet it's a good use of our time
as goku is wondering if beerus is really
training vegeta
whis asks him if that's a problem and he
responds and i quote navaji is his own
man
i'm here to polish ultra instinct and
quote
and he just sits there meditating again
i love this i love how they each have
their different
paths and that there's clearly more than
one way to get to the final destination
which is to be the strongest in the
universe philosophically i prefer
goku's path but you can't deny that god
of destruction vegeta is such a cool
idea it's like major vegeta on steroids
and we all know how cool
that was even if that wasn't the most
moral version of him
and i love how as these two are
competing among each other to become the
strongest we says
yeah but the strongest may turn out to
be someone else entirely
obviously we know this is gonna be
granola at this point but i like how no
matter how strong our fighters get
there's always the chance of someone
else entering the picture and
challenging them if you're number one
today and you stop training and putting
in the work that doesn't mean you'll be
number one tomorrow you gotta keep
working on it and it's never guaranteed
and
it's a never-ending journey and
adventure it's also funny how the oracle
fish
says the strongest war in the universe
will rise soon and of course vegeta
thinks it will be him after he masters
destruction and that would have been a
good guess
if it wasn't for granola nevertheless we
get a very hyped moment for vegeta and
vegeta fans
should be loving the story right now
vegeta actually succeeds
in causing the explosion that results
from destruction
sure he starts off with the tiniest
pebble but it means he can do it
and as he implies he'll soon be
destroying larger and larger things
as he gains more and more mastery god of
destruction vegeta seems pretty
inevitable now
even if he doesn't actually take on the
specific role as a god of destruction
i still feel like that's going to be the
best thing to call him but we'll see if
they give us
any other names for it in the manga and
although i love the power upgrade i
would never actually want vegeta to
become a god of destruction in the sense
that he has to work as beerus does
because i much prefer him having
adventures on earth and chilling with
bulma and trunks when he gets a chance
i absolutely love to see how genuinely
delighted goku is for vegeta's
accomplishment
you know if the roles were reversed
vegeta would probably be mad and envious
that goku accomplished something he
didn't
in these moments goku is like the
perfect role model for how we should
behave in life and at other times when
he spares enemies who could destroy his
family and the universe he's not so
perfect which is okay too
we then jump to the planet cereal and
you gotta love granola super saiyan 3
like hair
right now very cool they do a good job
of actually
translating his newfound power and
confidence through his expression and
aura
he's definitely got a different vibe
about him now just as vegeta destroyed a
small pebble
here granola similarly destroys a large
boulder granola doesn't know what
technique that
was but clearly the story is suggesting
that it's the power of destruction
not only that he's got a better grasp of
it than vegeta from the looks of it but
this is just what it looks like right
now we're sure to find out more about it
in the future we then get an
interesting discussion between granola
and his own namekian friend who told him
not to go through with this idea
and now that granola has his namekian
friend tells him that there's no better
way
to make new enemies pop out of the
woodwork than by brandishing that sort
of power
that's actually a fascinating statement
and an idea that's come up a lot in
dragon ball the stronger our main
characters get the more they attract
stronger and stronger opponents
of course granola is not concerned by
the idea since he wants to attract
frieza and kill him once and for all and
when you know you're the strongest
person
in the universe you probably don't feel
that scared about strong opponents
showing up the question of course though
is how long will he remain the strongest
and could he take on two of the second
strongest opponents in the universe at
the same time and then if we get vegito
into the mix
that's a whole other story as well but
those questions and me looking forward
to them being answered is what makes
this arc so exciting for me as we see
granola cutting his epic locks
unfortunately
whis remarks that this may cause some
turmoil gazing at him through his staff
that's a foreboding statement if i ever
saw one and we
know that eventually the side story has
to clash with our main story with our
main characters since we've been
following it for so long
anyways granola goes to elec the space
crime boss
to get the facts on frieza we had a
similar scene recently but it's fun
watching the difference
now that granola has the power to back
up his insane ambitions
they think nothing's changed and he
wouldn't stand a chance against frieza
but when he takes down oil and maki
effortlessly in humorous fashion alex
sees what's up
and decides to treat granola differently
it was really funny watching granola
deal with them
while also clearly not trying to hurt
them badly because as he said
they're not his enemies granola's
revenge is very much targeted towards
people
who destroyed his race and he clearly
doesn't want to hurt anyone else it's
interesting how
elec makes granola reveal how he became
stronger he needs to believe that he's
the strongest so that frieza doesn't
come after the family and although
granola doesn't want to share at first
he decides that finding frieza is the
top priority so he tells him about the
dragon balls
i was also like bro there's no need to
tell them but i do sort of get
that he's on a clear path to revenge and
he's prioritizing that to practically
everything else even though that reveal
could lead the family to ask for the
same wish down the
line and to use the power in not so nice
ways
i love how oil responds by calling him
out for playing dirty i think we all
thought the same when the wish was made
and how it wasn't fair
since we've seen goku and vegeta train
their butts off
their whole lives and someone surpasses
them with a single wish but the price he
has to pay makes it better like when gon
got his short-lived power up in hunter
hunter it feels more fair this way
admittedly i did think three years was a
bit more time than i expected to see
one year or less probably would have
been a better direction to go in but i'm
sure the three years might be
significant down the line
when they realized he sold his remaining
life to beat frieza
the family thought he was insane but you
still can't help but respect the guy as
he calmly walks out of the room
a dude on a mission like this has an
aura about him and it definitely
impacted these guys
nonetheless the story foregrounds that
power is not
everything and granola seems to be
pretty naive despite his power boost
while elect tells him he'll call him
with the info about frieza and granola
agrees elek's
actually planning something else since
he wants to take over frieza's army and
granola would probably kill frieza's
army he decides that he'll let the
saiyans goku and vegeta
take care of granola granola also
doesn't know
that as maki reveals the family schemed
with frieza to attack
planet cereal for money so they should
actually be on granola's hit list
2 and yet they're the ones manipulating
him from behind the scenes
i hope we get granola getting his
revenge against these guys
at least if not against frieza anyways
alex's plan is to use the hatred granola
must have for the saiyans who helped
kill his people and directed towards
goku and vegeta the two insanely strong
fighters who beat moro against them
granola is sure to die
and they can steal frieza's army another
day and in the final panel
we're told that at last fate will bring
these three together
this is such a fascinating setup because
the bad guys are counting on our main
characters to beat
a relatively moral dude who just wants
those who killed his people to atone for
their sins that puts us the audience who
are constantly rooting for vegeta and
goku
in a weird position where we also want
what the bad guys want
namely for our main characters to get
stronger and to beat this new opponent
obviously i'm hoping that they figure
out what's going on and find common
ground before it's too late
but still if we had to choose between
granola and our boys we're picking our
boys
a few contrarians aside can't wait to
see how this goes can't wait to see
vegeta reach new heights
and to see how granola's revenge goes
i'm hoping he does get a satisfying arc
because i am really enjoying this
character so far but all we can do is
just wait and see what happens right now
anyways as usual let me know your
thoughts on this chapter and this arc so
far what are you looking forward to
seeing next the most
if you do enjoy these dragon ball super
reviews and want to keep them coming the
best thing you can do
is channel the super saiyan within and
smash that like button until it's blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future dragon ball
super videos
and while you wait for the next exciting
chapter to drop feel free to check out
our dragon ball version podcast where
i'm watching the series from beginning
to end with my friend who's never
watched the series before
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon here on youtube
who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost i want to
thank the patron of the legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself and
the most donated champion
of the world alpha sigma and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata acquire respect potay
heffa liam thompson
algertol dr cortman dustin scarlet
emperor otaku spidey life tinel baked
buddhist tungsten tarkis
and yuno and are pro hero to your
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kazadski
cricket xp rathu and aura
very gucci alicia actor bonnie parks
hinokami and water
joanne garcia the red haired raven ted
note 10
ice parky 65 fat boy games deadly saint
and soul rye
slice and dice thank you all so much if
you do enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get an a featured in
future videos alongside these
amazing epic people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patronly discord where we talk about
anime manga chapters life and of course
dank memes so check out our patreon.com
anime outpour link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next
subscribe button that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way if you
prefer
whichever way you choose support us you
can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you